news this afternoon a disturbing story
in the southwest valley
metro police say a woman was shot and
killed with her children nearby
this happened this morning in a home
near sunset and grand canyon drive
and right now detectives are still
looking for the person who did this
bianca holmen live now with an update
from the scene from police
bianca john the shooting happened
five hours ago it happened this morning
at seven but you can see
right behind me that police are still on
the scene here and this all happened at
the sunset canyon apartments
detectives say the woman was shot
several times by her boyfriend
and they're still looking for him
officers were called to the complex
around 7 this morning
detectives believe there was an argument
between the woman and her long-term
boyfriend over car keys
two children were inside the apartment
when the shooting happened outside
paramedics took the woman to umc where
she was pronounced dead
we actually had multiple people call 911
including the mother of the
deceased the victim was on the phone
with her mother when the incident
occurred so the mom was also
a person who called 911.
metro police say the man drove off after
the shooting
they're working on an accurate
description of him and the vehicle
now metro says that if anyone in the
community
knows about the situation or has a tip
to call crime stoppers where you can
remain
anonymous reporting from sunset in grand
canyon bianca holman
8 news now